Wow what is this here we go oh hey Gogol
with which tasty fake on weights that
Google homie need I have one home it
won't all right
let's unbox everything oh my god I'm so
excited
[Music]
yeah Wien looks everything there are so
many stuff so much yeah
you have a whole set of pants which is
awesome because not only would you get
matching pants but you get a lot of
different kinds of pants yeah and I love
the color
how many comets does it come sweetie
three : hmm I like red you like the road
yeah this is a very sexy pot I miss it
so we eventually use these pots and pans
in the tasty kitchen currently you might
have seen them in a few of our videos
but they're so great because not only do
they have the heat safe Silvan handles
they also have a really great nonstick
surface I've even made like a really
sticky caramel inside here and it
slipped right out so you know it works
one thing make me very excited
if this comic ball the ceramic bowls and
really useful you can use these for like
microwaving maybe for like a little
snack if you've ever watched a tasty
video you probably recognize these I'm
obsessed with them I love using them
because I want to measure everything
prep it's very important for cooking and
how much is that yeah I've always wanted
a Google mini and not only is it super
cute and cool you can actually cook with
it with tasty so it'll be like you're
right there in the kitchen with me Oh
[Music]
you stepping stone into thoughtful
touching pain yeah I have a cousin foods
going to go college thing so I think
it's a Greg GTFO college kid for sure
you know to start cooking so where can
you buy all this stuff
oh that's awesome because Walmart's are
everywhere they're all around the
country there are so many things we
should share without a pasty producer
yeah sure no I'm gonna keep going that's
why I own a github one right good job
unboxing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]